c'était enlevé qu'une punition je crois
qu'il s'en relèvera pas bureau de
monsieur rusk jeu par larry charles
monsieur je suis désolé c'est harold ça
n'a pas l'air d'aller
harold c'est quelque part au fin fond du
mexique avec quelques plans nicheurs
aaron l'avenir c'est cette pilule
d'herbe demain tu t'envoles pour le
mexique
quoi on veut que tu remettre la formule
de la pilule aux labos
[Musique]
ça sympa
rf et on vendait notre production au
cartel mais quand on a arrêté ils se
sont inclinés
il faut le sortir de là rapidement et je
connais quelques uns des forces
spéciales expert en extraction
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent une bonne
facture quoi en pestant entre l'afld
c'est quoi ça un micro mischer
injectables il faut que je puisse vous
suivre ce n'est pas les élus vous fait
pas peur avec vos histoires sur les gros
méchants cartel je sais comment ça
marchera pas au mexique
bon on y va aux deux stars
ceignac to put ça croyez vraiment en
dieu
bah oui naturellement que j'y crois quel
genre de personne ne croit pas en dieu
ben moi j'y crois un peu mais pas tant
que ça
les choses vont commencer à s'arranger
pour toi fais moi confiance je le sens
bien